[Music]
all right let's talk a couple of
spoilers right now I'm gonna start off
with your seagull first off does the
seagull have a name in the script the
seagull is called
one eye but the this the seagull the
seagull is played by three seagulls Lady
[ __ ] and Johnny there's something like
delightfully disturbing about all of
this when I remember what happens to the
poorest eagle can you talk a little bit
about weaving the seagull into the
script and what it means for Rob's
character well I didn't want another
black Philip was such a nightmare that I
didn't want to have another I want a
road movie with these two characters
yeah I didn't I didn't want to do
another leading character animal but my
brother
III but I did want the chaos to really
begin and the wind's to change with
Rob's character killing a sea bird so
and so my but my brother sort of
convinced me that having this prominent
one-eyed seagull character was a good
idea and so I took took the plunge but
it was
I mean seagulls are really smart
actually they were they were great like
the the goat who played black Philip
Charlie was not trained frankly and and
but these seagulls were amazing they're
you know Johnny was like good at calling
and you know lady was good at pecking
you know they all had their specific
roles why one I watch the movie again
and and there's like some one-eyed stuff
like yeah yeah sorry that's that but but
but but I would must say that the want
of what the one-eyed stuff in the movie
was sort was planned to be at the level
where if you go with a group of friends
okay be one of your friends when you're
having drinks after it's like oh no but
this you're like
okay by the time I see this movie again
and again when it hits theaters I'll be
able to have this conversation with
myself okay I also wanted to ask a
little bit about the mermaid and
incorporating that aspect to it and
again what that means for Rob's
character throughout his journey yeah I
mean I'm clearly staying away by what
anything means for anyone I know I know
sorry to do that guy do you have the
answer in your head like do you have
worse yeah you have something that like
you fully intend despite what everybody
out there interprets and everybody's
interpretation is very valuable that's
one of the things that excites me about
the movie yeah absolutely
but but but no I certainly like she has
a clear clear purpose yes my my wife's a
clinical psychologist and I invite her
colleagues to come to screenings because
usually they're very well read and and
they're able to like talk about what all
these different symbolic things mean
very specifically and it was interesting
to hear like what they had to say about
the mermaid whether it was in line or
not in line with say I don't but but no
the mermaid the mermaid was fun and and
and and and Valerie does an incredible
job and and and the the the the
prosthetic work was by Adrian Moreau and
Kathy says stunning like I I'm I'm glad
the films in black and white but the
paint job of the mermaid's tail was
amazing yeah it looks phenomenal my last
question for you right now is the last
shot of the film is that exactly how you
envision the movie ending when you first
start at this process or did that evolve
along the way my brother and I worked on
act 2 in act 3 like very collaborative
on an act two very collaboratively and
and then I sort of just wrote the first
pass of act 3 myself and my brother was
like that's I don't think we can she
that and I was like now I think it I
think it's the only thing we can do and
and and then as I think as he took Act
three and did his polishes on it he was
like yeah okay like I think I think this
is what we have to do okay thank you for
indulging me with this I mean that
really though the cool thing is it's a
challenging movie that sparks
conversation I'm all for 3d fleeting
thrill just an enjoyable time in the
theater but thank you for giving me
something not just to chew on but to
obsess over well thanks thanks for
asking good questions I appreciate you
saying that which is different quite a
different question hands down the best
thing I could have heard thank you again
congratulations